hey Burt this is only me but do you ever
wake up in the morning and just feel so
drained
but after Christmas snooze button three
times I think most of the time the worst
thought is I've got to go and do life
stuff right now but I'm quickly gonna
get another 15 minutes snooze time one
week earlier I travelled back to South
Africa from LA to plan my wedding down
here and while on the road Google gifted
me the pixel Booker and challenged me to
fulfill one of my lifelong ambitions
instead of focusing on another outward
activity to rather look inward piece of
tech is to rather use it as the
centerpiece in the most meaningful most
insightful firm I've made to date
alongside arguably some of the most
genius minds in the world
[Music]
[Music]
cute big Super Girl montage are
slick-looking
adjustable pixel of guards in all
seriousness though it's super portable
it looks really rad it's got the strike
rip button for prep and the battery life
is incredible at clasp up to 12 hours so
they have a display battery performance
is based on a mix of video web browsing
productivity and other use actual
results may vary
okay so the idea is this no non-invasive
brand placement I have challenged myself
to sit here in my office in Cape Town
and be vulnerable enough to look at the
camera and say that I've been far too
busy focusing on my career for the past
10 years of my life that I haven't
actually focused on building a
foundation feel like first day's I'm
just on the brink of Bernard I don't
even know the basics like how many hours
a night's sleep is considered okay or
why I constantly compare my life to
other people's lives online and why is
it that I care so much what other people
think about me therefore I'm going to go
on this journey to figure out how to
live sustainably in the 21st century we
all begin existence the same way as the
simplest thing you can imagine a simple
cell that becomes life a dozen a complex
prospect then in
color flexing we learn to walk and talk
and then the teen years the terrible
teens questions about love
that's your thority spots popular
attraction to others to ourselves voice
breaking confusion rhythm to the age
where you have to start thinking about
who you are and how you fit into the
bigger picture life becomes very real
very fast with so many distractions to
entertain our curious minds essentially
we are living in an era of unlimited
escapism it's been easy for me to just
keep as busy as possible so that I don't
really have to think about life staff
now I'm reaching the end of my 20s and I
still have so many questions questions
about the right way to live life what am
I supposed to eat simply considered
healthy if you look at any human life
like an empty vessel I believe there are
three fundamental components to
happiness but not just happiness I'm
talking about sustainable long-term
enjoyment they are health energy and
confidence so through this really rad
organizational tool currently in Cape
Town at 71 and mostly sunny
I have arranged over 30 different Google
Hangouts where I'm not going to listen
to answer but rather listen to
understand and talk parallels between
these fascinating insights shared from
my friends around the globe in your life
how would you define happiness do you
believe that there's a link between what
you eat and how you feel 118 itself may
be a lot more psychological than we
Nathan can is the easiest way to that
this would be healthy foods make you
feel good not before that beautiful but
that may not get very dangerous
how important is sleep it allows us to
sort through what's relevant for
personalities and well-being in a
survival rise to the top during sleep
and you kind of ingrained that into your
subconscious mind and process it if you
could explain your reasoning behind only
eating one major meal per day if you
take ten dietitians you'll be ten nights
you'll find that whole vegetables about
their time sometimes it ones hunting
their own idea of the time the very fact
that is so many variations of knives
means there's no times when I eat some
food I always crave something extremely
sweet they often it's purely an
addiction just like a cigarette or
alcohol it's an addiction and the
program is not the calories that you eat
there it makes you hungry
tomorrow and say eat more calories
tomorrow and then the next thing because
for a while I thought building like this
external validation helped me be more
confident I thought for so long that
building it around me will dancer but
the whole time that was fun to get
people there
how would you define confidence external
forces in life so the more confident you
are the less you the list you are making
decisions based on what other people's
judgments of you maybe I've always
defined my my happiness my
self-confidence based on my fault
I think that I'm a runner and you can
sprint and you can sprint really fast
and really far but you can't sprint
forever so if you want to be able to
sprint in life you have to know when
it's time to run and when it's time to
stop and catch your breath and I think
that in life is some sort of healthy
combination of both of those things for
me I find confidence through again the
crafting of an internal myth an inner
landscape a story that I tell myself
about myself gives me a North Star that
gives me something to point my efforts
at not because I'll achieve everything
but because I'm moving in the right
direction if you're not moving forward
you're falling backwards I think
happiness is a it's a feeling and
something that you don't necessarily
think about you know it's kind of like
something that it seems more like a
reflective the basis of what I've been
doing has been about really stripping it
down to what you need as opposed to what
you be told you means if your body is
not responding appropriately to your
eating plan your psychology will not be
right and we're getting to realize that
anxiety and depression are linked to
nutrition and that's the truth of it you
need to make sure that you're eating the
food that makes you happy content and
energetic there are lots of
concentration the key is lots of energy
and but the most important one is you're
never angry people they're terrific we
find are looking at you like what is
your secret yeah over here Rory you got
a handful each cut off that you clearly
look more self-confident and happy with
like that I do so what am I doing wrong
let me try to get close to you yeah so I
can sleep and that's just what it is
like that's it's a beautiful thing is it
there's a disarming thing
are you happy how do you you define that
happiness now that to you you're in LA
you say that you're happy but but you
know you wake up in the morning what
makes you happy
making things making videos and working
on movies and working on the kinds of
pursuits that are genuinely interesting
a friend of mine told me this idea that
if you wouldn't do it for $1 don't do it
for a million dollars I'm gonna think
about the things that are destined
myself in professionally right now I'm
working on a big movie and working at
YouTube videos I hope I get paid for
them but I would absolutely do them if I
knew I would never get paid for them I
would do them if I knew that lose money
doing them and that to me really shows
that doing the right thing I laid out
all these incredible insights gained
onto a really complicated human mind
back on the wall behind but my friend
Georgie helped me create this simple
infographic on how to nervous
namely happy life in the 21st century
health works as follows
the more processes your food has to go
through from source to consumption
generally the more unhealthy sleep is a
routine you should get into we can call
it a ritual of sorts disconnecting from
external information is highly important
because your subconscious mind needs to
absorb and make sense of what you have
consciously experienced in the day
before and this will help you set up for
the day ahead
[Music]
confidence fluctuates this is based
purely on your self-worth which which is
for some only through external
affirmations like millions of lights and
Instagram posts or being constantly
affirmed on the great job that you doing
at work your looks
etc or it could come from within and
living this kind of carefree not caring
about what other people think of the
parts you truly love about yourself I
believe for me living in a highly
connected world it's the perfect balance
between the two
overall what I've learned here and I
think what we can all agree on
especially in some of the stunning
contradictions we've heard and create is
that a better life the personal growth
is incredibly personal it's an inward
discovery truly listening to yourself
your vibe
your smiles your woes giving yourself
real-time so it yes to the beginning of
finding the solution for me I hope that
this video has helped you and encourages
you to look inward as well thanks to
Google for inviting me to take the next
step and complete this challenge and
then also to Wong foo for passing on the
baton make sure to check out the link in
the description for more information
about the pixel book good other than
that don't forget eurosam through and
I'll see you next week for a new video
[Music]